some of you might not know this but I
had eating disorders until I was in my
late 20s and as a result my boobs grew
in different sizes that's a side effect
for people when they have eating
disorders sometimes as your boobs grow
in a little bit differently I had to get
three surgeries to get them straightened
out one was bigger than the other one
one was higher than the other one they
they look like from the same general
family one was just like a shittier
version of the other one it was like
Alec Baldwin and Stephen Baldwin I kind
of just wanted to Stephens you know
or to Alex I'll take either at this
point and I was always still embarrassed
about them because before I'd get with a
guy I felt like I had to explain when he
was about to see I'd have to prepare him
you know I'd be like do you like
baseball and golf
do you like young women and old men you
don't have to choose big Salvador Dali
fan so the tragic irony of this whole
thing is that they're still not even
because one of the surgeons made a
mistake and they cut through a muscle I
know never get an operation by the
airport red flag I feel like I probably
should a saw and I hated them for the
last couple years I hated them because I
felt ashamed my whole thing is you know
accept who you are love your body and I
felt like a hypocrite cuz I had these
implants him so I resented having all
that work done for the longest time
until a couple years ago when I got in a
really bad snowboarding accident and I
broke my shoulder and I go into the
surgeon and he's like I don't understand
this injury makes no sense I see this
all the time when people fall forward on
a snowboard
they break their nose they get a
concussion you only broke your shoulder
how did this happen and in that moment I
realized that I bounced off my tits
and then my fate should save my life